well today I had positive conversations
with political parties in Northern
Ireland about our ongoing discussions to
resolve the Northern Ireland protocol
now it's clear that we need to find
solutions to the Practical problems that
the protocol is causing families and
businesses in Northern Ireland as well
as address the Democratic deficit now
there's more work to do and that's why
my ministerial colleagues and I will
continue talking to the European Union
intensely to find solutions that protect
the Belfast Good Friday agreement and
Northern Ireland's place in our single
market so Jeffrey Donaldson leader of
the dup says he wants to see the EU
stretch itself to achieve a deal is that
what you think you need to see and what
more does the EU need to do to get this
across the line well the test that I've
set myself is that we protect Northern
Ireland's place in our internal Market
that we protect the Belfast and Friday
agreement that we resolve the Practical
issues that the protocol is causing
families and businesses in Northern
Ireland and crucially that we address
the Democratic deficit those are the
issues that we need to work through and
that's what my ministerial colleagues
and I will be talking to the EU about
confident you'll get there I said
there's work to do we we have not got a
deal yet that's why the both the foreign
secretary and I but also the Secretary
of State for Northern Ireland will
continue talking to the European Union
to try and find solutions to protect
Northern Ireland's place in our internal
market and the Belfast Good Friday
agreement resolve the Practical issues
and address the Democratic deficit a
couple of other issues what did you
think about the level of information
released by the police about Nicola
bully well I agree with the Home
Secretary and like her I was concerned
that that private information was put
into the public domain and I'm pleased
that the police are looking at how that
happened in the investigation obviously
my thoughts are with Nicholas friends
and family and the focus now must be on
continuing to try and find her and
you're heading off to the Munich
security Conference next what do you
want to get out of that as an
opportunity for us to talk to and for me
to talk to our partners allies around
the world about our efforts to increase
our support to Ukraine so that they can
defeat Russian aggression we've
consistently led the way in this
conflict most recently improved being
one of the first countries to provide
main battle tanks to the ukrainians but
also to start training their soldiers
and aviators on NATO standard aircraft
you know I want to make sure other
countries follow our lead and continue
to support Ukraine in the way that we
are we want to make sure that Russia is
defeated and Saturday's conference gives
me an opportunity to talk to others
about that
thank you